all right guys we've got two very
powerful machines in the studio today a
battle versus Battle who is going to win
let's talk about it right now we have
the Apple MacBook Pro M2 Max 32
gigabytes of RAM we have two terabytes
of storage this is pretty much almost
maxed out a very expensive machine but
what PC counterpart can match this m
design chip this SOC design chip said
well we have from Asus the 16 inch
Zenbook pro has a supernova Som chipset
which is very similar to architecture as
the soc not quite there but very similar
where the ram is placed closer to the
CPU now we have a 12th gen Intel I9
processor inside of this we have an RTX
3060 graphics card by Nvidia we have two
terabytes of storage and 32 gigabytes of
RAM so when you look at these machines
they are very closed in specs but how do
they handle red 8K footage we're not
talking Sony here we're not talking
Nikon we're not talking Canon we're
talking red Cinema grade A footage these
are massive files we're going to put
them in Premiere and we're going to see
how they handle now you might be saying
to yourself right now hey wait a second
bye I already know the pro is gonna win
and I may say to yourself you may be
right or you may be
maybe a close battle at all we're gonna
find out but right now before we do that
here's a quick message from our sponsor
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
format function helps the Titan Evo 2020
to deliver the best seating experience
like no other for more information check
out secretlab.co alright let's look at
playback and scrubbing performance here
on the Asus we have to go to 1 16 to
even get something manageable out of
this these files are massive for this
machine unfortunately and it is very
difficult to edit a 10 minute AK raw
video with this so This Is Where The Red
footage is really gonna tax the Som
chipset versus the soc you're gonna see
that in just a bit looking at the
playback performance on the M2 MacBook
Pro this is where you're going to see
apple really shine now there are some
drop frames here and there but for the
most part you don't need to drop this in
a proxy or anything like that it
actually plays really well also you can
see the CPU performance on this it looks
good now let's render first and foremost
the mac and let's see how this goes now
we're going to be looking at a total
around 45 minutes thereabouts the fan
does kick on after the first minute then
after that it does kind of quiet down
but this is really taxing on any machine
especially at 10 minutes of 8K raw
footage from red and it does take about
45 minutes to render this however when
we get to the Asus surprisingly the Asus
is only about 11 minutes slower than the
Mac when it comes to rendering the same
exact footage because honestly thought
it was going to be a lot slower but Asus
did chug along very very well and it
held its own alright as we saw from our
Premiere rendering and editing and
everything else
we have a clear winner folks the MacBook
Pro M2 Max is just a beast of a machine
I mean the M1 Max is already a beast in
its own right the M2 Max has just kind
of put the nail in the coffin so to
speak but we have to give credit to Asus
here I mean look the soc design on the
chipset that Apple's using for their M
chips is fantastic and Asus is close to
the Som we have not tried the latest
version of the Zenbook Pro 16 inch it's
quite not a fair battle per se but it's
close enough to give you an idea I think
there's a lot of work with Asus to do
but I have to tell you something to give
ASU some credit here I love what they've
done with this machine the Ola display
is awesome the ergonomics of this are
fantastic the build quality out of this
laptop is friggin amazing and if you're
not shooting red video footage honestly
speaking would you notice that much of a
difference there may be some but I mean
if you go to 4K and everything else this
is going to be more than enough for you
and I just love how it's designed now
there are some nuances to this with the
MacBook Pro you can charge via USBC as
with the Zenbook you can't it needs
enough power so you have to use the
power fabric that comes with it which is
quite big that's a little bit of a
downside to it but you still have an SD
card uh card reader inside of it you
have your Thunderbolt 4 ports in this
and a track pad that is very versatile
which you can have as a number track pad
you can adjust to how you want it to be
there's a lot of customization to this
machine so for you PC people out there
don't think that just because Apple won
this battle that the Asus doesn't have a
seat at the table it definitely does but
when comparing this for red footage
ak-25p in Premiere Pro
Apple
how's the trophy they are the winners
anyway guys if you like this video
subscribe to the channel hit that like
button as well more content coming your
way and if you like this review check
out more more of our reviews right here